you see what uh what happened with The
Young Turks with Anna kaspberry oh it's
the most enjoyable thing on Twitter oh
my gosh let's talk about it what
happened
down so uh Anna can spreader The Young
Turks criticized this uh non-profit for
calling women's privates bonus holes
and the reaction others because she had
a problem with being called the birthing
person and stuff but the lightest one is
that she criticized Organization for for
referring to female parts as bonus holes
and what happened many leftist
commentators said she lied made it up
it's propaganda and not real yeah
shockingly insane and evil Anna is
correct and I agree with her opinion
however I do find her to be duplicitous
in that we've agreed with her and jack
on so many things but they always
pretend to oppose us which is the
weirdest thing ever if she came in here
and sat down we would be like you're
completely right on all of your points
100 yep that's absolutely correct we
agree we talked about the same thing the
left comes out calls her right wing
calls him shells and says no one's
referring to his bonus walls so she
tweets the link to it saying here's the
organization calling women's Parts bonus
holes and they still claim she's lying
because there's two big components to
what the left commentary does lie about
what's actually happening because
they're ideologues who believe there's
no truth but power so they're justified
in their lives to gain power or they're
saying whatever they think is
in in opposition to the right so if
anything criticizes them they're on the
other side of it if anyone says this
book is bad then the book must be good
so when Anna comes out and says don't
call me a birthing person or having a
bonus hole they say you're lying that
never happened or you're right wing
I noticed that same thing with uh elad's
uh footage of the marching the people
that were marching saying we're here
we're queer were coming for your
children and in the comments they're
like no no that was just a moment at the
March where it was out of some there was
somebody inciting that thing someone got
in the way and started that chant they
weren't really saying that I'm like I
just watched the video five times like I
saw him say it a lot and there were a
lot of people I don't have any evidence
that someone was there inciting that and
it just seemed like lies like it was
like a cognitive dissonant thing like I
cannot accept this I must lie I must say
it didn't happen it's that cycle where
first they said oh it's not happening
it's just conspiracy theory and they say
oh it's sort of happening doesn't matter
and then they say oh it's a good thing
it's happening and that's what NBC
eventually wrote that oh this is a
time-honored among the homosexuals
chanting that they're coming for your
children there's a normal thing they
always do that forever you should
definitely get Anna to come on the the
show we've invited them oh on here on
IRL she'd be so fun not just culture War
show all of the time because because
especially with her her making
apparently this is this is something
that's been going on for a while she's
been having disagreements uh she came
she was on Stitch and Adams uh oh yeah I
want to go on their show yeah they're
listening they're looking to get in
touch with you um but she came out and
she's said that you know
um uh the the Kyle Rittenhouse case she
understands you know and she's on Kyle
ritten's writtenhouse aside which is in
opposition to sanks uh chank's position
um she has an issue with being called a
birthing person or a uterus have or
whatever there's a lot of things that
are going on on the left that she's
started to have an issue with and you
know kudos to her because every other
sane liberal person who realized what
was going on became disaffected liberal
yeah you know and and like I said kudos
to her because she's taking a a ton of
hell for it but you know the fact that
she actually can acknowledge that look
this is a lie and one of the things she
said on the on the on Adam such and
Adam's stream was that people were
gaslighting her and she's like I know
that you're lying to me and and I I
can't believe that you are still
continuing to Gaslight me because it's
not about her yeah it's about the
listeners
so what's up what a lot of these
channels do which uh uh you know I'll
leave there's many of them they just
fabricate everything they don't care
either because they're ideologically or
capitalistically driven it's really
fascinating they're like oh I'm on the
left and they buy massive mansions in
California
complete lies these people it's
remarkable that you look to these
prominent lefties who are talking about
all this you know I believe in helping
people and socialism and it's like oh
who have you who have you supported and
donated to none how dare you uh and then
you look to the quote-unquote right I
love this thing about the pro-choice
pro-life argument when the pro-choicers
lie all the time no that's unfair it's
not pro-choice it is the pro-abortion
side and the pro-life side because the
pro-choices are like in the middle and
like typically not starting with
conservatives on a lot of issues I mean
like actual approach choice where they
were like maybe within the first few
weeks but post viability no abortion the
reasonable Democrat position from a
while ago the pro-abortion crowd is just
lying about everything
I forgot exactly where I was going but
uh that's basically the the gist of it
you've got people who have
found themselves silenced and in the
middle as the left just says whatever it
is is the opposite of the right and then
lies about what's actually happening to
wind power are you taking a post-birth
abortion now people are claiming that
it's not actually happening but they're
I mean oh yeah all the media claiming
that no one ever brought it up when
Northam literally talked about even
resuscitating the baby and then bring it
to another room to decide what to do
there's also a phenomenon of liars
people that think it's good to lie and
they like they just do it I had a friend
growing up in granted we were like 13 or
14 at the time but we would play
Dungeons and Dragons and then he would
he'd roll and then he'd be like no I got
a five I'd be like dude you just rolled
a seven you'd be like no I got I had a
five dude I'm like you you it was a
seven like that's gaslighting but then
we play with a third guy would come over
and he'd be like no it was a five and
we'd both be like you're lying to us you
just won the seven he's like no I rolled
a five and how do you get through to
someone like that you don't we just said
we had to cut ways and like ostracize
the reason they can get through or get
away with it is because whoever Their
audience is isn't a very narrow Channel
they're not like checking out a lefty on
The Young Turks and I'll watch them pull
and sort of get both sides of story
their audiences are completely locked in
with people just like them and think
like them so you like still have people
this day you know yelling about January
Sixers killing five police officers that
day which yeah no but they believe it
because all their news sources repeat
that same lie and they're not exposed to
anybody outside of that or when they get
like they run to me I say oh that's not
true uh the only people that died were
protesters unarmed protesters like oh
you're lying that's not true
so we have two different I guess
realities so here's the issue I see with
like The Young Turks
I I've known known them for a very very
long time like longer than 10 years back
when he was a conservative you know not
when he was a conservative I remember I
remember and then and they used to post
I guess they were Jimmy Dore said this I
could be wrong that they would post
photos of like upskirt shots or
something like that I don't know if
that's true or whatever it's been it's
been a while but was that what it was uh
that was uh Hassan Hassan started out
doing a lot of stuff like that Hassan
used to do that
kind of like the upskirt not not exactly
I'm not gonna say he did upskirt stuff
but he was like early YouTube guy
posting like you know girls edgy stuff
bro code
Young Turks have some like dark stuff
yeah but what I think happened with them
is they had a large audience the
cultural shift started to happen in 2015
and they did not want to go against
their own audience because
money was more important so they just
went along with whatever the current
thing was but eventually you break
eventually the left starts advocating
for insane things like post-birth
abortion unrestricted abortion calling
women birthing persons and have a bonus
hole havers and eventually you're just
like this is insane the problem I have
with the issue I take The Young Turks is
that
they're still trying to pretend to be a
part of whatever the left is yeah
they'll say things like well we are on
the left because we believe in universal
healthcare it's like oh so so do I and
I've talked about that quite a bit on
the show they'll say yeah well you know
we're pro-choice I'm like that's funny
so am I we've had debates me and Sheamus
discuss this all the time they're lying
they're still lying even though Anna is
pushing back against lies on the left
they still lie and pretend that they're
not in agreement with us on a lot of
issues they still pretend to support
things that are completely untrue even
when Anna says something that's correct
as soon as someone on the right
compliments her or says here's what you
write about she'll come out and say yeah
well you're not but I'm still not on the
right and I disagree with you he's like
just stop this whole like desperate need
to be on the left is so annoying that's
why I'm like you know I'll try and
Define it what does it mean to be
culture War right wing economically
right-wing or socially right-wing
definitions matter but I'll refer to
this as the freedom faction or the
culture War right like I don't care what
you call it so long as we understand
what we're talking about anyone that's
like I am a fill in the blank I'm a
conservative I'm a liberal I am a this
even I am an American like you are
putting yourself in a box man and it is
a dark hole you cannot see out of that
thing but is it a bonus hole probably
I'd be willing to bet that on most
issues I'm to the left of Hassan
hands down I hope he hears this I'd be
willing to bet that if we actually had a
discussion on issues I would be to the
left of him on a whole bunch of
different issues I'm not but he would
lie no no he would lie this is my point
like I'll put it this way
if uh someone came to him and wanted to
work on some project with him that he
would Finance do you think he would
actually give them the majority of the
revenue generated from the project they
worked on I believe the answer would be
no I believe he'd be like no way
no absolutely not whereas here we often
discuss how if we launch a project the
people will the people working on that
project will retain the majority of the
revenue generated from it the company
like we seek to Foster talent and and
help people grow
I've I've publicly donated to several
people in several causes I I like I'm
not trying to start beef with him or
anything like that I'm just saying I
think these people are just
entertainment personalities who will
claim to support a thing like Ethan
Klein or whatever they'll they'll
feigned being on a political side for
entertainment value but I guarantee you
if it ever came down to seizing the
wealth of Hassan he would fight
you tooth and nail he would take up arms
against a Communist Revolution in two
seconds to stop his his to stop the
seizure of his multi-million dollar
mansion in California I don't know about
that he's Bourgeois Bourgeois I guess
and I agree with you I don't like
talking about I don't want to cause
drama is a little Anna's awesome she's
brilliant remember that guy in
California who was cheering on the
rioting and post the photo of the Bernie
building and then as soon as they
started marching towards Beverly Hills
he was like no don't come here that's
what I'm talking about so I'm not saying
I know for sure maybe I'm wrong about a
son I don't watch a ton of his stuff but
the fact that even when I've tried like
when I've agreed with him and Anna they
still act like I'm wrong it's the
weirdest thing is that the way you
agreed no you were too it was too
tonally angry when I made a literal
video where I was like Hassan's totally
right and everyone's wrong to criticize
him here's why he's right he made a
video laughing at me oh where you guys
were either video response
picture-in-picture video response that
was funny but like he made a video and
then I responded to it saying he was
correct in his assessment here's why and
then he made a video saying that I was
wrong about a bunch of things and then
laughing at some of the points I'm like
I don't understand like I'm agreeing
with you it is fake money too the drama
is good for clicks and Views and AD
Revenue but it's we got to get to a
point where we get past that just well
Shuffle it off like ballast and get up
into orbit thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time